this is Luna the killer whale a five  year old Orca filmed in Nootka sound  Canada doing an impression of a boat  I've never seen something like an orca  come this close to a boat let alone  trying to talk to it so why is a killer  whale trying to converse with a boat so  nuna is a male Orca that has become  separated from his pod ordinarily orcas  lives socially in their maternal family  groups and they communicate with each  other making vocal clicks and whistles  so mimicking each other is an incredibly  important part of strengthening the  bonds between them but Luna grew up  hearing the sounds of boats so Luna  began to associate those with the sound  he should make and learn to imitate  boats before getting here is an  incredible insight into how sociable  orcas are and how they communicate and  it gives us a real sense of their  intelligence ordinarily this would be  incredibly difficult to film  you